m cadets frappé de plein fouet par la
bataille tarifaire
l'entreprise qui fabrique des citernes
en acier et en aluminium doit absolument
s'approvisionner sur le marché américain
le bassin sont pas disponibles qu'à
radio qu'un fournisseur votre pari qu'un
canadien en important les feuilles des
états unis raismes car doit payer une
surtaxe de 10% imposé par le canada en
représailles au tarif de
l'administration tron sur un horizon
d'un an le fabricant perdre à 750 milles
dollars
ouest france et se rencontraient à la
paire point car devant nos prix du
marché mérité pour se soustraire aux
tarifs et continuer de vendre ses
citernes un prix compétitif aux états
unis c'est là que l'entreprise va
prendre de l'expansion et non au québec
on a regardé pourquoi d'expression pour
nous le meilleur choix concrets mais pas
des plus belles royaux prince m'a
raconté tiger dans l'espoir de pousser
les américains à suspendre leurs tarifs
le gouvernement trudeau menacent de ne
pas ratifier le nouvel accord de libre
échange
mais le temps presse le conflit pèse de
plus en plus sur des transformateurs de
nuit minium il ya déjà des joueurs qui
sont tombés au combat et un ado qui
pourrait être preuve en problèmes dans
les prochains mois et c'est toute une
industrie qui finalement fait très peu
de profits actuellement dans cette
dispute commerciale le groupe canal qui
fabrique des structures d'acier estime
que les américains ont déjà réussi à
imposer leurs vues moi je pense que les
états unis je serai pas gagné mais ils
créent une crainte tellement forte
qu'elle craint qu'une entreprise a
décidé bon mais la prochaine usine je la
mets ou mais je vais remettre aux états
unis la levée des tarifs ne signifierait
pas nécessairement à la fin des mesures
protectionnistes l'administration turin
par visage de les remplacer par des
quotas sur les importations d'acier et
d'aluminium au delà desquelles des
surtaxes
toujours impliquée ici olivier bachand
et radio canada c'est jean sur richelieu